bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans votre
journal de l'afrique à la une de
l'actualité du continent le soudan où
des milliers de personnes sont à nouveau
sortis dans la rue ce lundi une
contestation durement réprimé les forces
de l'ordre ont tiré à balles réelles sur
la foule sept manifestants ont été tués
nous parlerons de hauts lieux du mali au
lendemain de la mort d'ibrahim boubacar
keïta et les autorités de transition ont
communiqué sur les obsèques de l'ancien
chef d'état elles auront lieu vendredi à
bamako
puis enfin on parlera football avec la
can qui se poursuit le cameroun fini
premier de son groupe alors que le
burkina faso lui a dû arracher son
ticket pour les huitièmes de finale
après son match face à l'ethiopie cédric
ferreira nous attend sur place
on commence donc cette édition avec le
soudan la contestation se poursuit la
répression aussi ce lundi pour la
première fois les forces de sécurité ont
utilisé des armes lourdes au moins sept
manifestants ont été tués les détails
avec maya anaïs iata guen
une pluie de grenades lacrymogènes
s'abat sur ces militants anti-putsch
venus manifester à nouveau dans les rues
de khartoum face aux forces de l'ordre
équipées d'armes lourdes les
contestataires n'ont pu ériger que des
barriques appli fortune plusieurs morts
sont à déplorer ainsi que de nombreux
blessés cette journée sanglante est une
nouvelle étape dans le bras de fer entre
l'armée au pouvoir depuis le coup d'état
du 25 octobre et les partisans d'un
gouvernement entièrement composé de
civils
nous espérons que notre révolution de la
liberté rejoindra le chemin de la
démocratie exercées par des civils
j'espère que le peuple soudanais
atteindra ses objectifs
je suis contre la tyrannie
les dictatures et tout autre régime qui
s'oppose à la liberté et la justice pour
le peuple
je m'oppose à toute inégalité au sein du
peuple soudanais
que ce soit en termes de liberté
d'expression ou de répartition des
richesses
les manifestants refusent
catégoriquement toute négociation tout
partenariat avec l'armée les militaires
eux accusent les militants d'entretenir
le chaos d'où la création d'une toute
nouvelle force spéciale antiterroriste
pour faire face à de potentielles
menaces neuf des quinze membres du
conseil de sécurité de l'onu ont appelé
toutes les parties à faire preuve de la
plus grande retenue notamment pour
éviter toute déstabilisation
supplémentaire au darfour voisin un des
manifestations antigouvernementales il y
en avait aussi ce dimanche en tunisie à
moindre échelle plusieurs de nos
confrères ont été violentés et ce lundi
paris dénonce des violences policières
inacceptables contre les journalistes
ce sont des relations qui reste
extrêmement tendue celle entre la france
et le mali ce dimanche paris par la voix
de son ministre des affaires étrangères
un jean yves le drian a affirmé que la
france resterait dans le pays mais pas à
n'importe quel prix et de son côté
bamako envisage de revoir les modalités
de cette collaboration militaire écouter
wassim nast les notre journaliste
c'était une discussion écrite que j'ai
eu avec abdoulaye diop les affaires
étrangères malien où il m'a annoncé que
le mali avait demandé officiellement
des amendements concernant les accords
le traité de défense qui lient les deux
pays parce que selon ce qui m'a dit
c'était en contradiction avec la
position malienne selon ses dires j'ai
pu confirmer avec les autorités
françaises différentes autorités que oui
effectivement le mali a demandé des
amendements fin décembre dernier mais
que ça reste est plus ou moins secret et
le fait que les affaires étrangères
'l'annonce me le disent c'est comme
monte d'un cran dans la pression donc
ils demandent des amendements sur le
terrain après les opérations françaises
militaire soyons clairs ne sont pas
entravés pour le moment parce que les
accords ne sont pas dénoncés mais c'est
une demande pour qu'il soit revu et les
avions de la misma sont cloués au sol
depuis vendredi aujourd'hui une
négociation entre la minustah et les
autorités maliennes qui ont échoué
m'a-t-on dit et à quelques minutes et
donc les avions seront encore cloué
aujourd'hui et demain exception faite
des ce qu'on va dire d exfiltration
médical terminus main ne qu'on voit pas
juste les membres de l'onu mais c'est le
fret en fait entre bamako et le nord où
tout le monde et qu'on voyait les
officiels maliens les ong ont dit les
lads humanitaire donc les premiers à
payer le prix aujourd'hui quand une
catastrophe humanitaire econostrum et
climatique c'est la minus manquent à
l'appel donc les premiers à payer le
prix aujourd'hui ce sont les maliens à
cause de ce bras de fer on va dire entre
bamako et paris et l'entêtement des
autorités en tout cas malienne dans
cette voie qu'ils ont choisie donc
d'aller du côté on va dire des russes
est d'essayer de faire partir d'évacuer
la france et ses partenaires sur zone le
mali où après l'annoncé hier de la mort
de l'ancien président ibrahim boubacar
kéita les modalités de ses obsèques ont
été en partie dévoilée elle devrait se
tenir vendredi prochain à bamako la
capitale un hommage officiel sera rendu
les échanges se poursuivent entre la
famille d'ibrahim boubacar keïta est la
junte au pouvoir un communiqué avec tous
les détails devraient être prochainement
communiqué
lui aussi a été chassé du pouvoir par un
coup d'état militaire alpha condé a
quitté la guinée ce lundi l'ancien
président âgé de 83 ans s'est envolée
pour les émirats arabes unis selon les
sources de france 24
après onze ans à la tête du pays alpha
condé a été renversé par l'armée en
septembre dernier
encore une journée riche en émotions au
cameroun où se tient une coupe d'afrique
des nations au goût particulier avec des
équipes qui ne partait pas favorite et
qui donne désormais des sueurs froides
aux plus grandes sélections cédric
ferreira bonsoir à vous vous êtes sur
place pour france 24 le burkina faso a
donc arraché sa qualification dans la
douleur
un match difficile jusqu'au bout pour
les burkinabè face à l'ethiopie mais ils
ont assuré l'essentiel en se qualifiant
donc pour les huitièmes de finale la
coupe d'afrique des nations on a assisté
à un match assez serré car c'est vrai il
faut le rappeler c'est un match décisif
pour les deux équipes au coup d'envoi à
la bonne nouvelle du côté des étalons
c'était le retour de quatre joueurs
testés positifs au coville 19 récemment
le retour notamment du capitaine de
l'équipe bertrand traoré en revanche
l'épidémie commis 19 qui continue de
jouer des tours aux burkinabè puisque
cette fois c'est le gardien titulaire à
hervé koffi qui a été testé positif il a
été remplacé par farid ouédraogo auteur
de plusieurs parades décisives dans la
rencontre le gardien qui a multiplié les
arrêts de très grande classe surtout
lorsqu'il a permis aux de protéger l
avantage acquis par les burkinabè en
première période grâce au but marqué un
but marqué par à cyril balaïa
l'attaquant qui évolue ajaccio france
auteur d'un magnifique lob ensuite les
éthiopiens vous vous en doutez ont
poussé pour égaliser ils se sont heurtés
à une solide défense burkinabè l'un des
points forts d'ailleurs de cette équipe
mais les éthiopiens qui sont quand même
parvenus à leurs fins en obtenant un
penalty après consultation du vidéo
arbitrage penalty marqué par get année
kebede pour l'ethiopie les deux équipes
en sont donc restés sur un match nul 1
partout le burkina faso termine deuxième
de ce groupe a avec 4 points à égalité
point d'ailleurs avec le cap vert mais
lors de la confrontation directe entre
les deux équipes les burkinabè s'était
imposé ils ont donc l'avantagé au
classement pour l'ethiopie c'est
définitivement terminé
les éthiopiens qui termine dernier ce
groupe a avec un point cela fait
maintenant plus de cinquante ans que
l'ethiopie n'a plus passé le premier
tour d'une coupe d'afrique des nations
la suite maintenant c'est donc ce
huitième de finale pour le burkina faso
les burkinabè qui peuvent nourrir
l'espoir d'égaliser leur meilleure
performance en coupe d'afrique des
nations avec une finale disputée en 2013
voilà pour ce match 1 du burkina faso
qui n'a pas lâché donc on peut le dire
mission accomplie également pour le
cameroun qui lui assure la première
place du groupe à
et oui cette fameuse première place qui
permet d'avoir un adversaire plus
abordable en huitièmes de finale même si
les lions indomptables aurait quand même
préféré terminer sur un carton plein
avec trois victoires en trois matches
elle est cette rencontre a été plus
difficile que prévu pour les lions
indomptables et pourtant au coup d'envoi
le sélectionneur avait aligné une équipe
quasiment identique aux deux premiers
matches on s'attendait à voir des
remplaçants gagner un peu de temps de
jeu et surtout faire des choix qui
permettrait de conserver un peu de
fraîcheur pour la suite en tout cas
c'est un choix du sélectionneur qui a
été payant puisque le cas monde a vite
pris l'avantagé dans cette rencontre
grâce à un nouveau but de vincent
aboubakar le capitaine de cette équipe
on est déjà à cinq buts en trois matches
dans cette coupe d'afrique des nations
il est évidemment pour l'instant le
meilleur buteur de la compétition mais
le cap vert qui jouait sa qualification
n'a pas lâché et les capverdiens ont
réussi à égaliser par gary rodrigues
l'attaquant qui a d'ailleurs marqué l'un
des plus beaux buts de cette coupe
d'afrique des nations le cam on a eu
quelques occasions mais a laissé passer
sa chance et donc les deux équipes se
sont quittées sur ce résultat nul 1
partout le cameroun est donc qualifié
pour les huitièmes de finale disputera
dire ce huitième de finale lundi
prochain cameroun premiers du groupe
avec sept points le cap vert est 3e avec
4 points mais ce n'est peut-être pas
terminée pour les cap verdiens car ils
sont très bien placés pour être repêché
dans ces huitièmes de finale même s'il
faudra attendre les résultats des autres
groupes le cap vert qui rejoint pour la
première fois le deuxième tour d'une
coupe d'afrique des nations depuis 2013
2013 d'ailleurs où ils avaient réalisé
leur meilleure performance avec un quart
de finale elle cédric ferreira ans et
spécial de france 24 au cameroun on peut
voir juste derrière vous cédric le
fameux quart de l'équipe algérienne et
bien les algériens il faut le dire
qu'ils sont désormais dos au mur après
un match nul et puis hier aussi après
une défaite face à la guinée équatoriale
mais les fennecs peuvent encore se
qualifier pour les huitièmes de finale
il va falloir seulement il faut le dire
remporter le match face à la côte
d'ivoire le renverse techer
un début de can cauchemardesque pour
l'algérie battue 1 0 par la guinée
équatoriale dimanche les champions
d'afrique en titre se retrouve dernier
de leur groupe et pourraient être
éliminés avant même les huitièmes de
finale malgré le choc et la déception
des supporters algériens venus soutenir
leur équipe à douala continue d'y croire
s'y attendait pas tout simplement ils
ont été assommés hier soir on la rentrée
on était en cette parenté des bus on
n'en sait pas quoi faire bon bah
effectivement on a perdu et voilà
maintenant on est dos au mur on n'a pas
le choix et ben
faudra tout donner c'est tout les
algériens ont pourtant dominé le match
avec près de 70% de possession de balle
et une dizaine de tentatives mais aucune
des stars de l'équipe n'est parvenu à
trouver le chemin des filets pour
l'entraîneur des fennecs qui refuse de
blâmer ses joueurs c'est signe que le
niveau du football africain est de plus
en plus élevés aujourd'hui la plus
petite équipe en afrique
qu'à voir
le match cet après-midi mali gambie et
qu'à voir l'image du sénégal - quasiment
toutes les équipes sont sont dans la rue
la difficulté je les dis dès le début du
iii pour espérer se qualifier l'algérie
doit impérativement battre la côte
d'ivoire jeudi la rencontre promet
d'être explosive car les éléphants
ajouté également leur qualification
après un match nul rocambolesque face à
la sierra leone une chose est sûre cette
coupe d'afrique des nations n'a pas fini
de surprendre
et puis le gabon lui dispute son
prochain match de demain face au maroc
mais ce sera sans les deux stars
aubameyang et mario les mines à tous
deux positifs au kovy 19 depuis
plusieurs jours maintenant alors avec
l'accord des médecins il quitte donc
officiellement la compétition pour
rejoindre leurs clubs respectifs
arsenal et nice
il avait été boudé durant le ballon d'or
le sénégal et edward mendy a été élu
gardien de l'année par la fifa va
prendre sans plus tarder la direction de
dakar où nous attend notre journaliste
elimane dao donc soirée liman c'est donc
une belle revanche pour le gardien de
chelsea
une belle revanche c'est d'ailleurs les
réactions j'ai parcouru depuis cette
information et les réactions qui dit il
sont les plus partagés les supporters
sénégalais estime qu' il mérite et non
seulement de figurer parmi les 30
meilleurs joueurs du monde il a été
happé de la liste de france football le
magazine français mais également de
remporter le progrès les machines du
meilleur gardien à de l'année que l'on
trouvait distribué par là par france
football edouard mehdi selon tous ses
supporters c'est légal et même par
fuiter on peut dire mérite cette
récompense
de sa saison exceptionnelle avec les
blues de chelsea il a remporté la ligue
des champions et des meilleurs buteurs
également de la ligue des champions et
au but est tout simplement de son
parcours en tant que footballeur en 2012
il était au chômage n'avait pas de club
il le dit lui-même il n'avait pensé
abandonner le football avoir de voir sa
chance avec la réserve de l'olympique de
marseille quelques années plus tard de
signer au stade de reims aurait ensuite
au stade rennais est un début 2020 il a
été repéré par tienne cycle le club
anglais
elle remporte la ligue des champions
edouard mendy qui était positif aux
convives 19 depuis le début de la coupe
d'afrique des nations en fait à prendre
service au buteur des lions du sénégal
le sénégal qui joue deux mais la face au
malawi elimane dao correspondant de
france 24 à dakar merci à vous elimane
pour toutes ces précisions et c'est la
fin de ce journal de l'afrique tout de
suite l'information revient sur france 5
[Musique]